m
[Musique]
l'histoire est écrite par les vainqueurs
tout ce que nous savons des peuples
assassiné est ce que les assassins ont
voulu en dire
si nos ennemis remporte la victoire si
ce sont eux qui écrivent l'histoire de
cette guerre
ils peuvent aussi décider de nous comme
est complètement de la mémoire du monde
comme si nous n'avions jamais existé
[Musique]
tout a commencé en cette journée de 1935
au moment où je pris conscience des lois
de nuremberg
je ne devint pas plus juive que je ne
l'était une demi heure auparavant
les près de mon visage n'était pas
subitement devenus ses mythiques
dans la menace de mort que je ressentis
bien clairement pour la première fois se
trouvait déjà ce que l'on a coutume
d'appeler la dégradation méthodique des
juifs par les nazis
être juif dès ce moment cela signifiait
pour moi être un mort en sursis un homme
à abattre
des affiches ont été placardées aux
coins des rues
des sections du parti nazi et du parti
de la jeunesse hitlérienne se forme dans
la ville
défilé chant procession
le chef du heat l'ère jürgen par taille
la jeunesse hitlérienne a fait un long
discours est ce qu'il a dit pourrait se
résumer en une phrase
nous allons nous débarrasser des juifs
parce qu'il n'y a pas de place pour eux
dans le riche
envie de rester à la maison de ne pas
sortir de ne rien voir de tout ça
il est dur d'être stigmatisé je me
demande comment la population va se
comporter
va-t-elle suivre
j'en ai plus qu'assez des vitrines des
affiches des uniformes brin des bras
tendus faisant le salut hitlérien des
slogans perpétuelle des drapeaux icd
petite moustache taillée à la hitler
j'étouffe au royaume de la haine et de
la violence
je n'en peux plus de respirer cet air
empoisonné
les jours prochains on va brûler
publiquement les livres juifs et
marxiste dans les rues c'est une
barbarie inouïe mais ceux qui
protestaient s'habitue déjà la barbarie
et peu à l'indignation s'atténue
tous les juifs sont regroupés dans les
mêmes immeubles avec obligation d'y
rester après 20 heures
il invente chaque jour de nouvelles
mesures pour nous briser lentement
interdiction d'écouter la radio
d'utiliser de téléphone d'aller à la
piscine au théâtre au cinéma au concert
au musée dans une bibliothèque un
restaurant
une gare ou un jardin public de monter
dans les tramways d'acheter des journaux
des fleurs du café du chocolat des
fruits d'aller chez le coiffeur de
posséder une machine à écrire un vélo
une chaise longue interdiction de
posséder un chien un chat ou un oiseau
voilà je crois que c'est tout
le peuple allemand ne peut plus tolérer
que des centaines de juifs règne encore
à l'intérieur de nos frontières sur des
rues entières de magasins qu'ils
empochent l'argent des allemands tandis
que leurs frères de race incite au
dehors à la guerre contre l'allemagne
on m'a souvent posé la question pourquoi
n'avez vous pas quitter l'allemagne
pourquoi n'êtes vous pas partie à temps
nous n'avions plus de passeport et nous
n'avions plus d'argent non plus parce
que après la nuit de cristal les nazis
ont imposé une amende aux communautés
juives une amende destiné à débarrasser
les débris qui jonchent et l'allemagne
après la destruction des biens juifs
cela s'est traduit par la confiscation
de tous les comptes en banque alors
comment on fait pour partir quand on n'a
ni passeport ni nationalité puisqu'on
n'avait plus la nationalité allemande et
pas d'argent comment on fait pour
émigrer
on trouve encore parmi notre peuple des
gens qui ne sont pas intimement
convaincu quand nous parlons de
l'extermination des juifs dans notre
espace vital il nous a fallu trouver
parmi nous la force de caractère et
l'énergie du plus grand homme a paru
dans notre peuple depuis milan afin
d'arracher l'imposture juive qui nous
aveugle est les juifs espère nous
contraindre à une vie d'esclave afin de
prospérer sur notre dos en parasites et
de nous exploiter qui dans ce combat
peut encore invoquer la pitié qui
croient encore dans la possibilité
d'améliorer un parasite impôts par
exemple ou de le convertir qui pensent
qu'il existe un moyen de trouver un
compromis avec un parasite nous n'avons
qu'un seul choix nous laisser dévorer
par le parasite ou l'anéantir le juif
doit être anéanti par tous nous le
trouvons
le führer de nouveau exprimé sa
détermination nettoyer l'europe des
juifs sans pitié il ne doit pas y avoir
le moindre sentimentalisme émotif à ce
sujet les juifs mérite la catastrophe
qui a déjà commencé à les engloutit leur
destruction accompagnera main dans la
main la destruction de nos ennemis nous
devons hâter ce processus avec une
froide inflexibilité
[Musique]
le règlement définitif de la question
juive signifiant l'extermination totale
de tous les juifs d'europe je reçu
l'ordre d'organiser l'extermination aa
chute tout le travail aide lors du
déshabillage remplissage vidage des
chambres à gaz incinération des cadavres
aussi bien que le creusage et le
remplissage des fosses communes sera
accompli par une corvée spéciale de
juifs qui seront tenues à pas et qui
selon les instructions deichmann devront
être exterminés eux aussi après chaque
opération importante
commande ou services agricoles de schwyz
objet conformément à un ordre du
commandant du camp les fours crématoires
seront pourvus d'une bande verte servant
de limites naturelles au camp voici la
liste des plantes qui devront être
prises dans la réserve forestière
200 arbres à feuilles de 3 à 5 m émile
arbustes de revêtement de 2,5 mètres de
haut le tout prix dans les réserves de
nos pépinières
de chaumière abandonné dans un bois de
birkenau ont été transformés en chambres
à gaz de chaumière propre et jolie
séparées l'une de l'autre par un petit
bois au milieu d'un charmant paysage
elles avaient été peintes à la chaux
d'un blanc éclatant leur toit était de
chaume et elle s'était entourée d'arbres
fruitiers
seul un observateur attentif pouvait
s'apercevoir de l'existence de deux
écriteaux portant l'inscription vers la
désinfection il remarquer alors que les
maisons n'avaient pas de fenêtre mais
que leur porte était étonnamment robuste
munis de garnitures hermétique en
caoutchouc et de fermeture vis sur
lesquels on avait placé d'état rejette
de bois
dès l'automne de l'année 1941 on a
commencé à procéder au gazage dans une
salle du petit crématoire qui avait été
aménagée à ses fins
quand la crémation était bien lancée en
jeter dans le foyer les autres cadavres
ont collecté avec des sauts de la grèce
qui coulait sur le sol et on l'a rejetée
au feu pourra telle opération
la durée de la crémation était de 6 à 7
heures la puanteur des corps brûlés se
faisait sentir dans toutes
c'est crémation de cadavre était une
opération tellement affreuse du point de
vue de l'esprit de la vue de l'odorat
que personne ne peut en imaginer
l'horreur
tandis que nous dînions on s'est mis à
parler de la question juive dans le
monde
c'est pour moi très intéressant
d'entendre de telles conversations
à mon grand étonnement
tous furent finalement d'accord pour
dire que les juifs devaient disparaître
de la surface de la terre
mais ce n'est là qu'un souhait
[Musique]
mort aux juifs morts à la vilenie à la
duplicité à la rue juive mort à tout ce
qui est faux laisse à la répugnant
négroïde métis est juif c'est le dernier
recours des hommes blancs traquer volet
dépouille est assassiné par les sémites
et qui retrouve la force de se dégager
de l'abominable étreinte mort aux juifs
c'est l'appel ultime d'un peuple darien
qui est tombé dans le piège gluant de la
générosité et que les fauves judaïque
ont assailli mort aux juifs oui répétons
le mort m au rt aux juifs le juif n'est
pas un homme c'est une bête puante on se
débarrasse des poux on combat les
épidémies on lutte contre les parasites
on se défend contre le mal contre la
mort dont contre les juifs les juifs
veulent nous faire définitivement crever
eh bien ils crèveront avant nous mort
aux juifs morts à tout ce qui est juif
faisant suite à une instruction du
quartier général les mots déportation
vers l'est ne doivent pas être employée
dans les avis ayant trait au départ
forcé pour tous les avis ainsi que
contre toute la correspondance il y aura
lieu de se servir de l'expression envoie
pour travaux forcés
en vertu des pleins pouvoirs qui m'ont
été conférés j'ordonne ce qui suit signe
distinctif pour les juifs il est
interdit aux juifs dès l'âge de 6 ans
révolus de paraître en public sans
porter l'étoile juive l'étoile juive est
une étoile à six pointes ayant les
dimensions de la paume d'une main et les
contours noirs elle est en tissu jaune
et porte en caractères noirs
l'inscription juifs elle devra être
portée bien visiblement sur le côté
gauche de la poitrine solidement cousue
sur le vêtement les infractions à la
présente ordonnance seront punis
d'emprisonnement
la présente ordonnance entrera en
vigueur le 7 juin 1942
vu la loi portant sur le statut des
juifs est la loi du 29 mars 1941 créant
un commissariat général aux questions
juives nous maréchal de france chef de
l'état français
décrétons l'accès et l'exercice fonction
énumérés ci-après sont interdits aux
juifs
chef de l'état membre du gouvernement
ambassadeur de france préfet sous-préfet
fonctionnaires attachés à tout service
de police préfecture au ministère de
l'intérieur membres des corps enseignant
officiers et sous-officiers des armées
de terre de mer et de l'air
les juifs ne peuvent exercer une
profession libérale commerciale
industrielle ou artisanale
sont interdits aux juifs les professions
ci-après banquiers agents immobiliers ou
de près de capitaux marchands de biens
courtier directeur rédacteur même au
titre de correspondant local de journaux
et toute entreprise se rapportant à la
radiodiffusion
les juifs ne peuvent donner un emploi
artistique dans des représentations
théâtrales dans des films ou dans des
spectacles ou donner des concerts vocaux
ou instrumentaux ou y participer
les juifs atteints par ces interdictions
devront cesser d'exercer la profession
qui leur est interdite
ce qui m'a stupéfait bouleversée c'est
la bonne conscience de tous ces gens qui
livrait les juifs de pologne et d'europe
centrale avec une espèce d'austérité
d'abnégation d'ardeur au travail en se
drapant dans leurs vertus les gens de
vichy cette odeur de sainteté du
pétainisme ces gens que je connaissais
bien et qui feignait de ne pas me
reconnaître quand il passait à un mètre
de moi il se sentait plus pure de ne pas
me serrer la main à moi juif
les délais du groupe des amis antijuifs
adressent leurs sentiments dévoués et
respectueux aux autorités d'occupation
au chef de la police allemande du franc
crèche et le prie de croire à leur
respectueuse reconnaissance le groupe
des amis anti juif s'engage à veiller à
ce que les mesures contre les juifs
soient strictement appliquées les amis
souhaitent également que ces mesures
soient complétées par la séparation
totale des enfants juifs dans les écoles
et les lycées il demande en outre que
les juifs ne soient pas autorisés à
utiliser des vélos taxis leurs
conducteurs sont à rien et il est
inadmissible qu'un juif avec son étoile
se fasse transportés par un aryen il en
est de même pour les porteurs de bagages
français enfin il doit être interdit aux
juifs porteur d'une étoile de faire
cirer leurs chaussures dans les gares ou
dans les rues
à l'office central de sûreté du reich
bureau 4 berlin objets solution
définitive de la question juive en
france
référence entretien avec le ssh man à
paris
monsieur rené bousquet a déclaré que les
juifs de nationalité française devront
être déportés mais que la police
française ne se prêtera pas l'exécution
de cette mesure celle ci sera effectuée
par des forces allemandes mais la police
française organisera une rafle en
arrêtant les juifs de nationalité
étrangère ces juifs seront remis à la
police allemande il va sans dire que les
deux catégories de juifs vont être
déportés
frères et soeurs d'après les
informations que nous recevons de source
sûre les allemands vont organiser une
rafle et une déportation massive de
juifs
le danger est grand
fermer les yeux devant la réalité
tragique est égal à un suicide ne pas
attendre à la maison prendre toutes les
mesures pour se cacher et pour cacher en
premier lieu les enfants
barricadé les portes appeler à l'aide on
n'a rien à perdre on peut juste y gagner
la vie
chercher sans cesse à fuir
paris 16 juillet 1942 les gardiens et
inspecteur après avoir vérifié
l'identité des juifs mission d'arrêter
non pas à discuter les différentes
observations qui peuvent être formulées
par eux ils n'ont pas à discuter non
plus sur l'état de santé ils rempliront
les mentions figurant au dos de chacune
des fiches indication du lieu
d'arrestation et le nom de la personne à
qui les clés auront été remises
les agents chargés de l'arrestation
s'assure lorsque tous les occupants du
logement sont emmenés que les compteurs
à gaz de l'électricité et de l'eau sont
bien fermées et que les animaux soient
confiées au concierge
dès le matin les juifs ont été
systématiquement arrêtés des femmes ont
été emmenées dans des cars de police
sans avoir eu le temps de s'habiller des
malades ont été obligés de quitter leur
lit des vieillards ont été emmenés de
force les parents séparés de leurs
enfants des familles entières établi en
france depuis plusieurs générations
l'embarquement se fait dans des
conditions particulièrement cruel
entassés dans des wagons à bestiaux sans
eau et sans nourriture
[Musique]
un officier à la demande de nourriture
pour ces malheureux répond nos soldats
meurent de faim
ces juifs là n'ont pas besoin de manger
on frappe à la porte de notre
appartement mon père ouvre et dans
l'encadrement se présentent deux agents
de police de la police française hélas
ils ont des fiches individuelles au nom
de mon père de ma mère de ma soeur et de
moi même mon père nous avait fait
préparer à tout hasard une petite valise
d'effets personnels pour chacun d'entre
nous et nous ont demandé de les suivre
et au moment où je prends cette petite
valise je me dirige vers mon cartable
j'en sors un atlas alors que personne ne
me regarde je rage rapidement la carte
de l'allemagne je plie cette carte en
quatre et je la range dans ma veste
comme si comme si je partais en voyage
comme on se munit d'une carte pour
savoir où l'on va et par quel itinéraire
on va passer
lors d'une conférence de presse vendredi
dernier monsieur pierre laval a annoncé
que le gouvernement de vichy était prêt
à faire une concession en ce qui
concerne la déportation des enfants
juifs
ils seront désormais déporté avec leurs
parents au lieu d'être séparés il a
ajouté cependant rien ni personne ne
pourra nous détourner de la politique
qui consiste à épurer la france
d'éléments indésirables sans nationalité
après avoir traîné marchande est
discutée verser quelques fausses larmes
les tenants de vichy acceptèrent
résolument de violer le droit sacré
d'asile de livrer à l'ennemi détester il
est destiné à une mort certaine des
troupeaux de femmes et d'hommes
d'enfants et de bébés bien sûr il s'agit
d'étrangers seulement d'apatrides pas de
français on avait acheté la vie sauve
des juifs français contre celle des
juifs étrangers on en était très fier
plus tard on achètera la vie des
français non juifs contre celle des
français juifs on sent montrera très
fier jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus de
marché à conclure on comprit alors qu'on
était tous vendus
il fallait que le monde entier senti
qu'à la place où brille est d'ordinaire
tant de lumière il n'y avait plus qu'un
grand trou noir d'où ne jaillissent et
plus aucune parole aucune pensée et que
ce trou noir fillon au monde
au vel d'hiv douze mille juifs sont
parqués c'est quelque chose d'horrible
de démoniaque quelque chose qui vous
prend à la gorge et vous empêche de
crier je vais essayer de te décrire le
spectacle mais multiplie le par mille et
une aura seulement qu'une partie de la
vérité
en entrant tu as d'abord le souffle
coupé par l'atmosphère empuanti
et tu te trouves dans ce grand vélodrome
noir de gens entassés les uns contre les
autres
ils ont à peu près 1 m² d'espacés chacun
quand ils sont couchés
les quelques wc qui lie au vel d'hiv
sont bouchées
tout le monde est obligé de faire ses
déjections le long des murs
l'état d'esprit des gens de ces hommes
femmes et enfants entassés là est
indescriptible
des hurlements hystériques
des cris libérez nous
des tentatives de suicide
il y à des femmes qui veulent se jeter
du haut des gradins elle se précipite
sur toi tu es nous mais ne nous laissez
pas ici une piqûre pour mourir je vous
en supplie et tant d'autres et tant
d'autres
on voit ici des tuberculeux des infirmes
des enfants qui ont la rougeole la
varicelle
on est même allé chercher les opérer de
la veille dans les hôpitaux d'où
éventration hémorragie
les bassins reste plein à côté d'eux car
on ne sait pas où les vider
j'ai vu aussi un aveugle et une femme
enceinte
il y a trois médecins pour 15000
personnes et un nombre insuffisant
d'infirmières
nous avons reçu comme consigne
surtout ne raconte rien de ce qui se
passe ici au dehors
cet ignoble on voudrait faire silence
autour de ce crime épouvantable
mais non nous ne permettrons pas il faut
qu'on le sache il faut que tout le monde
soit au courant de ce qui se passe ici
mon cher papa
j'espère que je te reverrai bientôt
essaie de me faire sortir ainsi je serai
avec toi ici je perds toutes mes forces
j'ai beaucoup maigri je suis encore
malade
il y a des gens qui disent qu'on va
libérer les enfants qui ont moins de 16
ans
je pleure souvent pensons à toi
et petite fille qui t'aime kate embrasse
bien fort
nous avons insisté dans la matinée au
départ des enfants
pendant qu on les faisait monter dans
les cars avec leurs mains ce bagage des
scènes déchirantes se sont produites les
enfants les plus jeunes qui ne pouvait
comprendre les raisons de cette
séparation
s'accrocher à leurs parents et
pleuraient les aînés qui savaient
combien la douleur de leurs parents
étaient grandes tentes est de dominer
leur peine les femmes sont accrochés aux
portières des cars qui parque
et nous parle pour l'inconnu
on a beau entendre dire que l'on envoie
les enfants retrouver leurs parents et
ne pas savoir ce qui les attend
la nouvelle du départ est accueilli dans
le camp comme une grande catastrophe
on nous emmène dans une petite gare près
de drancy où nous sommes obligés
d'embarquer avec nos baluchon dans des
wagons à bestiaux garer à l'écart
à midi le convoi s'ébranle
mille personnes dans des conditions
incroyables
entassés avec des sauts à peine de quoi
boire alors qu'il fait vraiment très
chaud et qu'il n'y a que de très petite
ouverture pour laisser passer un peu
d'air
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le train et partons
pour une destination inconnue
j'aurais voulu vous embrasser encore une
fois mes pauvres enfants que je ne
verrai plus
ne te sépare pas de michel ne vous
laissez pas mettre à l'asile
demandez aux foreurs d'en face peut-être
aura-t-il pitié de vous je vous sers
contre mon coeur en pleurant je vous
écris ce petit mot on est 45 dans les
wagons à bestiaux je suis parti ce matin
à 9h30 on est plus de 1000 qui partent
on approche de la frontière allemande
j'ai bon espoir à mettre sous enveloppe
et adressé à l'adresse ci dessous merci
davance aux bons soins de la personne
qui trouvera ce mot sur poulette je suis
dans un wagon à bestiaux pour la
déportation
j'espère retrouver maman
on nous a fouillés hier on n'a plus
d'argent
je n'ai reçu aucune nouvelle de paris
vous embrasse très bien mon frère vous
lui direz que j'ai beaucoup de courage
vous embrasse raid aura aussi
j'espère qu'on se reverra bientôt
j'ai écrit ça en quelques minutes je
n'ai pas le temps ni la place de
continuer
je vous embrasse de tout mon coeur est
très fort
simone
je remercie beaucoup celui qui remettra
ce mot il me rendre à un grand service
je ne sais pas si cette lettre vous
parviendra
nous nous trouvons dans un wagon à
bestiaux
on nous a enlevé jusqu'aux objets de
toilette les plus nécessaires
pour un voyage de trois jours nous avons
à peine du pain et de l'eau au compte
gouttes
les besoins nous les faisons sans nous
gêner par terre femmes et hommes
il y as parmi nous une morte
quand elle agonisait j'ai appelé au
secours
mais les wagons sont plombés elle est
restée son secours
et maintenant nous devons supporter
l'odeur de la mort
ma soeur et moi nous nous encourageons
mutuellement et nous espérons quand même
je vous embrasse tous les enfants la
famille et les amis
sarah
un train arrivait avec quarante cinq
wagons contenant plus de 6000 personnes
1500 déjà mortes à leur arrivée
derrière les petites lucarnes au fil
barbelé des enfants terrifiés ces
convois sont composées uniquement de
tout petits enfants ils sont accompagnés
de quelques infirmières ou assistantes
sociales des maisons d'enfants dans
lesquelles il se trouvait au moment de
leur arrestation
il en est ainsi de convois d'enfants
partis de drancy quelqu'un a dit vous
voyez il amène des enfants maintenant
ceux affectés à ce service avec des
cravaches de cuir font sortir les juifs
de l'intérieur des wagons
nous sommes 60 dans notre wagon dans une
cinquantaine d'enfants
je suis la seule monitrice du centre de
luge eev
les portes sont violemment ouvertes et
les enfants sont réveillés par des
hurlements
raul genel dehors vite il fait nuit mais
des projecteurs nous éclaire violemment
les enfants terrorisés son tir est
dehors par des hommes en costume rayé de
bagnard
l'un d'eux me dit en français surtout ne
prend pas de gosses dans les bras
je ne comprends pas je lui demande
pourquoi
tu comprendras d'ici quelques jours
la situation est terriblement
angoissante
je vois une petite fille toute seule qui
pleure je la prend par la main l'homme
revient vers moi et sur un ton très
autoritaire me dit tu n'as pas compris
ne prend pas d'enfant par la main
alors le coeur serré je laisse la petite
au milieu de la foule et je marche seul
le long de la voie ferrée
je me rends compte que tous les petits
enfants partent d'un côté avec les
personnes âgées
il ne reste que des gens qui ont entre
18 et 35 ans les allemands procède à
cette sélection comme s'il s'agissait de
bestiaux au marché et c'est ainsi que
disparaissent les neuf petits enfants
dont je me suis occupé pendant plusieurs
mois
à l'entrée du camp un ss sélectionner
les personnes âgées et les enfants aucun
enfant de 14 ans au moins entrer par
chance avant son arrestation maman
m'avait fait faire une coiffure qui me
vieillissaient une déportée française
m'a ordonné si on te demande ton âge tu
dis que tu as 16 ans je suis passé de 14
à 16 ans c'est pourquoi je dis toujours
que je n'ai jamais eu 15 ans
la première impression est de se trouver
transporté sur une autre planète dans le
spectacle paraît irréel une immense
plaine de terre boueuse
on sent que l'on bascule subitement dans
un monde totalement fou est inconnue une
haute cheminée crash en plein jour des
flammes orange
quand nous sommes arrivés dans le camp
la première chose qu'ils ont faite a été
de nous à tous et j'étais le matricule
numéro 78 1599
puis on nous a rasé les cheveux
à ce moment là quelques femmes de mon
groupe on commençait à poser des
questions aux femmes qui nous tendait
quand est-ce qu'on verra ceux qui sont
montés dans les camions elles nous ont
répondu jamais ils ont tous été menées
dans les chambres à gaz c'était
forcément faux ça ne pouvait qu'être
faux aucune d'entre nous n'arrivent à y
croire elle disait ça par méchanceté
jalousie je ne me souviens plus dans
quel état j'étais je ne sais même pas si
j'ai pleuré
puis des gardiens allemandes sont
arrivés et nous ont tout pris et nous on
attribuer un numéro
j'avais le 75 mille quatre cent
quatre-vingt dix ans nous a tondu et
donner des vêtements rayés des sabots et
un fichu et on nous a laissés dans un
baraquement de femmes on était milbach
baraquements
la baraque est pareille à une énorme
grange au lieu de plancher il y à issy
de la terre battue est au milieu de la
baraque des couchettes les traverses de
bois diviser la longueur de la baraque
en cage chaque cage était profonde
d'environ deux mètres et sa hauteur ne
dépassait pas un mètre
chacune d'elles devait contenir de cinq
à sept personnes mais parfois on
entassait une dizaine de plus on y
pénétraient comme dans une niche dossier
on y était totalement privé d'air
en l'espace d'une minute nous dormons
tous serrés coude à coude derrière les
paupières à peine close les rêves jaïs
avec violence et ce sont les rêves
habituel nous sommes chez nous en train
de prendre un merveilleux bain chaud
nous sommes chez nous assis à table
tandis que nous ne nous agrippons au
sommeil pour qu'ils ne nous abandonne
pas tous nos sens sont en alerte dans la
tente horrifié du signal qui va venir
qui approche qui le voit si house tout
le monde dort debout tout le monde se
lève s'entraîner devant mes yeux un
corps se balancent un homme s'est pendu
dans la nuit mon voisin quand le bras
vers deux autres pendues un peu plus
loin cela n'a rien d'exceptionnel il y
en a même moins que d'habitude
il me raconte qu'on en ait vaincu tous
les jours quelques-uns des personnes ne
prend plus garder ces détails je regarde
les pendus je les envie d'avoir trouvé
la paix
le travail physique exténuant les
brutalités des surveillants la
nourriture insuffisante l'époux entraîné
une mortalité effroyable
et tout cela était calculée et voulu
tout le système était de tuer lentement
ce que l'on avait pas exterminer dès
leur arrivée
il faudra rester des heures immobile
dans le froid et dans le vent 1800
famille sont mortes en l'espace de trois
mois si par malheur quelqu'un s'était
perdue ou noyées dans les toilettes tout
le camp rester debout jusqu'à ce qu'on
le retrouve
les latrines était composé de planches
dans lesquels étaient simplement percer
des trous on était assis les uns à côté
des autres et il fallait faire très
attention de ne pas tomber car derrière
nous et en dessous de nous c'était le
vide rempli de merde il arrivait que des
capots en rigolant pousse l'un ou
l'autre pour s'amuser mais ce local dès
la rentrée du travail avant mais surtout
après la distribution de la soupe
servait de lieu de rencontre pour tous
ceux qui avaient quelque chose à
échanger
toutes les transactions se faisait là
c'est pour cela qu'on appelait la bourse
j'étais affectés aux travaux extérieurs
et un jour j'ai reconnu mon père parmi
les prisonniers
lui aussi m'avait vu et nous nous sommes
jetés dans les bras l'un de l'autre
les allemands nous ont séparés à coups
de crosse de fusil et j'ai perdu
connaissance
quand j'ai repris mes esprits j'ai senti
quelque chose dans mes poches
un oignon et une pomme que mon père
avait réussi à me glisser à l'insu des
gardiens
c'est la dernière fois que je les ai vus
à drancy il m'avait dit toi tu
reviendras peut-être parce que tu es
jeune mais moi je ne reviendrai pas
il avait raison
on ne peut pas imaginer combien c'est
dur la fin à auschwitz ils nous
donnaient une soupe une soupe
c'était de l'eau avait quelques petits
bouts de pommes de terre qui flottait et
c'était la soupe pour toute une journée
ou bien ils nous donnaient une petite
pomme de terre ou encore un tout petit
bout 2 1 vous n'osez pas manger le pain
entièrement parce qu'on voulait en
garder pour après
il y avait deux sujets que les détenus
d'auschwitz considéré comme une espèce
de tabous les crématoires et la
nourriture
parler de nourriture augmentait par voie
de réflexes conditionnés
l'appétit lorsque quelqu'un se mettait à
parler de la nourriture qu'il mangeait
chez lui nous savions que cet homme ne
s'intéresseraient plus à son entourage
n'exécuteraient plus les ordres et ne
réagirais même plus en vue d'
expérimenter un soporifique vous
serait-il possible de mettre à notre
disposition quelques femmes et à quelles
conditions nous offrons 170 marque par
sujet veuillez donc va préparer un lot
de 150 femmes saines que nous enverrons
chercher très prochainement
nous sommes en possession du lot de 150
femmes votre choix est satisfaisant quoi
que les sujets soient très amaigri et
affaibli
nous vous tiendrons au courant du
résultat des expériences
les expériences n'ont pas été
concluantes les sujets sont morts nous
écrirons prochainement pour vous
demander de préparer un autre lot
le sort des juifs mais totalement
indifférent qu'il meure ou non de faim
cela ne m'intéresse que dans la meuse
nous avons besoin d'esclaves sinon cela
ne m'intéresse pas nous allemands sommes
les seuls au monde à avoir une attitude
correct envers les animaux nous aurons
également une attitude correcte envers
ces animaux humains
dans le camp la sélection se passe de la
manière suivante brusquement un soir
après la rentrée du travail les blocs
sont consignés et aucun détenu n'a le
droit de quitter son bloc dans chaque
bloc pas ce soit des ss soit des
médecins déportés ont fait défiler
devant te d'un pas accélérer la totalité
des détenus de ce bloc nu de face et de
dos tous ceux qui sont très maigres sont
inscrits sur une liste
le médecin jauge du regard les hommes
qui défilent un regard qui n'exprime que
morgue et mépris à chaque malade qui
passe il fait signe de l'index tendu en
déplaçant simplement le doit à gauche ou
à droite à gauche seront ceux qui auront
la vie sauve à droite les condamnés à
mort ceux qui iront à la chambre à gaz
toute la scène n'a pas duré une heure la
plupart des inscrits sont hébétés ne
parle pas ne bouge pas assis sur l'ogre
à bas ils sont l'air perdue dans un rêve
lointain détaché de tout les plus jeunes
peurs cachées sous leurs couvertures
je reste recroquevillé dans mon lit et
j'évite de rencontrer les regards de
ceux qui sont inscrits pour mourir
nous sommes consternés car nous savons
qu'ils sont condamnés à mort nous
mentons assez malheureux et nous leur
disons qu'on va les transférer dans un
autre camp la plupart ne se font aucune
illusion sur le sort qui les attend
heureux ceux qui sont tellement exténué
qu'il ne réalise plus et sont devenus
absolument indifférent
après un dernier appel ils montrent tout
nu dans les camions poussé par les coups
de crosse et des coups de gourdin le
regardons les camions se dirigeait vers
les fours le camion amène quelques 70 à
80 femmes ou hommes qui ne se font pas
d'illusions sur leur sort
ceux qui ont été choisis pour être tués
savent qu'il n'ya pas d'évasion possible
au pied de la cheminée du crématoire ils
n'ont même plus la force de descendre de
la haute plateforme du camion les
gardiens ss hurle et les presses le
sous-officier qui conduisait le camion
perd patience il s'installe au volant et
les normes ben déverse ceux qui s'y
trouvent des malades à demi moore tombe
sur la tête sur le visage les uns sur
les autres sur le béton scène atroce
devant lui des gens l'un après l'autre
tombe sans vie sur le sol cédant la
place aux autres en quelques minutes il
ne restera plus de qu'une poignée de
cendres
il y à une entreprise d'extermination
des juifs qui est en cours deux sources
différentes et toutes dignes de foi nous
apprenons que les juifs sont tués en
minces on rapporte des scènes
effrayantes qu'il est difficile de
croire je n'arrive pas à penser qu
hitler poursuivre un but pareil nie
qu'il y ait des allemands capable de
donner de tels ordres
notre peuple devra expier ses
monstruosités un jour ou l'autre
à cette époque la pologne comptait déjà
trois autres camps d'extermination de
belzec treblinka et maidanek je me
rendis à treblinka pour voir comment
s'effectuent les opérations
d'extermination
le commandant de treblinka me dit qu'il
avait fait disparaître 80 mille détenus
en six mois
cependant ces méthodes ne me parurent
pas très efficace aussi quand j'installe
est le bâtiment d'extermination darche
fils mon choix se porta sur le zyklon b
que nous laissions tomber dans la
chambre par une petite ouverture
il fallait compter de 3 15 minutes pour
que le gaz cuisson effet
nous apporte à mme également une autre
amélioration par rapport à treblinka en
construisant des chambres à gaz pouvant
contenir deux mille personnes à la fois
alors qu à treblinka leurs dix chambres
à gaz n'en contenaient chacune que 200
nous apporte à mon corps une autre
amélioration par rapport à treblinka où
les victimes savait presque toujours
qu'elle allait être exterminé à
auschwitz nous allions leur faire croire
qu'elle allait subir un aiguillage
il ne se passe guère de jour sans qu'il
y ait des gazages chaque fois nous
avions à nettoyer le crématoire tout
entier comme les ss nous donner des
ordres pour préparer les fours en les
faisant chauffer nous savions quand un
convoi était attendu
quand on ouvrait les portes des wagons
rien ne bouge et la plupart des juifs et
est mort debout mort de froid mort de
faim
un jour dans un de ces wagons quand on a
écarté l'entassement de cadavres je les
ai raid on a découvert tout un groupe
d'enfants juifs
tout à coup sûr le quai de la gare sur
la neige parmi les arbres couverts de
neige il y a eu ce groupe d'enfants
juifs une quinzaine environ regardant
autour d'eux d'un air et tony regardant
les cadavres entassés comme des troncs
d'arbres regardant comme des enfants
regardent
et les ss ont eu l'air embêté comme s'il
ne savait que faire de ces enfants de 8
à 12 ans bien que certains par leur
extrême maigreur par l'expression de
leurs regards us l'air de vieillard
[Musique]
au printemps 1944 à auschwitz a atteint
son zénith de long train faisait l'aller
et le retour entre le camp de birkenau
et la hongrie 3 voies allant jusqu'au
nouveau crématoire permettait de
décharger un train alors qu'un autre
entrait en gare
nous sommes partis dimanche matin et
nous sommes arrivés mardi nous ne
savions pas où est vieux agoniser les
enfants hurlaient au moins 20 personnes
sont mortes avant d'arriver à auschwitz
je me souviens que ma mère m'a serré
contre elle et elle m'a dit je suis si
heureuse qu'on soit tous ensemble quoi
qu'il puisse nous arriver au moins nous
serons tous réunis nous ne savions rien
de ce qui nous attendait ils ont ouvert
les portes et nous ont dit de sortir le
plus vite possible vous pouvez enfin
respirer un peu d'air
ils ont commencé à hurler les hommes et
les plus jeunes sur la gauche les mères
et les enfants sur la droite nous étions
si nombreux on ne pouvait même pas
avancer on se bousculait est brusquement
j'ai aperçu ma mère l'allemand qui
triait les gens s'est jeté sur moi parce
que j'essayais de rejoindre ma mère il
m'a frappé et m'a repoussé j'ai levé la
tête et j'ai vu ma mère s'en aller avec
mes deux petits frères c'était fini
pendant une fraction de seconde
j'aperçus ma mère et mes soeurs
s'éloigner à droite je les vis
disparaître au loin et je ne savais pas
quand cet endroit à ce moment je me
séparer de ma mère est de type aura pour
toujours jeter un coup d'oeil vers mon
père comme il avait changé tant
d'événements était arrivé en quelques
heures que j'avais complètement perdu la
notion du temps quand avions donc
quitter nos maisons et le ghetto et le
train une semaine une nuit
les juifs de hongrie sont arrivés en
wagon à bestiaux et ont été aussitôt
précipité sur la rampe de birkenau qui
venait d'être prolongée pour être plus
proche des chambres à gaz
jour après jour les trains se sont
succédé
alors que le débarquement avait déjà eu
lieu sur les plages de normandie
les nazis parachevaient leur oeuvre de
haine et envoyer à la mort près d'un
demi million d'hommes femmes et enfants
de ces enfants femmes vieillards
presqu'aucun est entré dans le camp
presque tous dès leur descente des
wagons étaient conduits vers les
chambres à gaz
j'ai vu atterré
ces visages décomposés ces femmes qui
portent les jeunes enfants et
soutiennent les grands ces foules encore
ignorante de leur destin qui marche vers
les chambres à gaz
pour nous qui savions impuissant ce qui
les attendait c'était une vision
d'horreur
mais ce qui nous hante ai par dessus
tout c'est que non seulement nous
allions dans l'indifférence des nations
être tous anéantis
mais c'est qu'il ne resterait aucune
trace de notre extermination
notre convoi était le troisième de la
longue série des convois de juifs en
provenance de hongrie
ma mère et mes cinq frères et soeurs
furent aussitôt envoyé aux chambres à
gaz
au moment de la sélection nous ignorions
à quoi servait cette répartition mon
père et moi affecté au camp avec les
aptes au travail
nous dûmes nous présenter à l'appel
devant le ss à ocha fureur molle il nous
a accueillis avec ces mots ici vous
aurez à bouffer mais il vous faudra
travailler
moi le choisit les plus forts d'entre
nous et on au mna de l'autre côté d'abu
mon coeur la façade de nous révéler rien
de particulier mais l'arrière nous fit
voir à quoi il servait ils y étaient
entassés un amas de cadavre nu
ce soir là on y tatouage sur le bras nos
numéros de détenus et on nous affecta
aux under commando jeu reçu le numéro à
3,076 notre groupe furent répartis en
équipes de jour et une équipe de nuit
les thunder commando dorment dans les
crématoires même un étage au-dessus des
fours
chacun sait qu'il est un mort vivant
nous apporta à manger mais aucun de nous
n'avait fin le matin nous nous
présentions à l'appel dans la cour on
nous a menés sur le lieu du travail
tandis que l'équipe de nuit pouvait
alors se coucher on travail consistait
au transport des cadavres l'évacuation
des cadavres
on est environ six heures
mais à ça ça nous oblige à raser nos
soeurs quelques minutes avant de les
envoyer à la mort
et non morts en sursis nous obéissons
sous l'autorité du fouet
nous marchions sur les cheveux de
différentes couleurs qui couvraient tout
le plancher du baraquement comme un
tapis épais de peluches
une fois toutes les femmes du transport
tendu quatre ouvriers utiliser des
balais pour rassembler tous les cheveux
dans un grand pas multicolores
il chargeait à la main les cheveux dans
des sacs de jute et les apporter à
l'entrepôt
oranienburg le 6 août secret objets
utilisation des cheveux
l'office central ss pour l'économie a
ordonné de récupérer les cheveux des
détenus femmes dans tous les camps après
avoir été coupée des peignées et
désinfectés ils seront transformés en
feutre et permettront de fabriquer des
pantoufles la quantité de cheveux
rassemblés mensuellement doit mettre
communiqué
l'entrepôt pour les cheveux des victimes
des chambres à gaz se trouvait à l'écart
dans un petit baraquements les sacs de
cheveux et les sacs de vêtements étaient
entassés séparément un wagon de
marchandises entièrement empli de sac de
cheveux étaient envoyés tous les deux ou
trois jours
nous nous trouvons devant les chambres
de la mort un haut parleur donne les
instructions
enlevez tous les vêtements même les
prothèses et les lunettes avec les
petits morceaux de ficelles à attacher
les chaussures
remettre toute valeur tout argent
quelques chefs de bloc s'entretenait
avec eux de la manière la plus anodine
pour leur donner confiance
très poliment leur faisait un petit
discours vous arrivez de voyage vous
êtes salle vous allez prendre un bain d
habillement vitesse
on leur dit qu'ils doivent se rendre
dans les pièces dites dépouillage puis
ils se rendent tranquillement dans les
pièces où on devait les désinfecter les
gardent leur ordonne d'enlever leurs
vêtements et de les suspendre
auprès de chaque crochet il y avait un
numéro et on leur recommandait de bien
retenir ce numéro
tous ceux qui avaient encore des paquets
devait les déposer devant la salle de
déshabillage chacun devait nous et ses
chaussures et les emporter avant de
pénétrer dans la chambre à gaz il devait
remettre ses chaussures en passant à
deux détenus dès que les femmes étaient
déshabillés un commando de chez nous
devez enlever les vêtements
des camions arrivaient et un groupe du
sonderkommando il chargeait séparément
les vêtements et les chaussures pour les
désinfecter mais cette fois il
s'agissait d'une désinfection réel
puis il en portait les vêtements et tous
les bagages restés sur la rampe à
l'endroit du tri dénommé canada
plusieurs femmes avaient été affectés au
canada on nous avait réparti en
plusieurs groupes il y avait une équipe
de jour et une de nuit
j'étais affecté à l'équipe de nuit
chargé de trier les vêtements des femmes
nous devions en faire des paquets de
douze
les vêtements devaient être
soigneusement pliées et ensuite ficelé
ceux ci étaient ensuite entassés dans
une autre aux baraques pour leur
transport de là des camions partaient
tous les jours pour les livrer en
allemagne
secret
6 février
la liste ci-jointe indiquent les
quantités de textiles usagés récupérer
dans le camp d'auschwitz
en annexe à ce document vous trouverez
une liste des 825 wagon de vêtements
usagés livré au ministère de la jeunesse
et à d'autres administrations allemande
ainsi que cinq cent soixante dix wagons
chargés de la récupération industrielle
des vêtements hors d'usagé
on me donne la même tâche que la veille
au tri des vêtements je tombe sur la
robe que ma soeur portait je
m'interromps je prends la robe je la
tiens entre mes mains quelques minutes
et je la contemple
je la montre à mon voisin il s'arrête
lui aussi un instant et me plains mais
très vite il se reprend et me crie
ressaisis toi à quoi ça sert
j'arrache un morceau de la robe et le
cash dans ma poche je les conserver
pendant dix mois
dans une baraque un peu à l'écart ont
trié les objets de valeur les bijoux
l'or et les autres objets précieux
tous les vêtements devaient être
soigneusement palper à la recherche de
bijoux cachés en or de diamants ou de
pierres précieuses
l'argent liquide doit être versée à
l'office central ss pour l'économie et
l'administration
les devises bijoux pierres précieuses et
perles doivent être remis à la banque du
reich les sous-vêtements et les
vêtements d'hommes peuvent être remis à
l'organisation dette sociale pour les
allemands les sous-vêtements les
vêtements de femme en pure soie et les
fourrures envoyés directement au
ministère de l'économie
les parapluies sac à main ceintures en
cuir miroir valises lunettes et les
lorgnons ainsi que les montres et
pendulettes stylos rasoirs ciseaux lampe
de poche portefeuille et porte-monnaie
doivent être envoyées aux ateliers de
réparation
un thunder commando un juif de paris
nommé david l'air était souvent sur
place
il était artiste peintre et pendant tout
le temps ils avaient pour unique tâche
de faire des dessins pour les ss ils
étaient dispensés de tout autre travail
il y avait un thunder commando un
certain léon juifs polonais qui avait
vécu à paris nous étions très liés les
on prenait des notes dès le moment où il
fut affecté au thunder kommando il
tenait une sorte de journal où il notait
les crimes des ss aucun d'entre nous n'a
lu ses notes qu'il voulait enfouir mais
je savais qu'elle existait
cher découvreur de ses écrits ce n'est
qu'une part infime de cet enfer qu'est à
auschwitz birkenau
je me tiens prêt d'un groupe de femmes
elles savent tous comprennent tous qui
si ce ne sont pas des bains que cette
salle et le corridor de la mort
l'antichambre de la tombe chacune veut
savoir si son mari son père son frère
est toujours en vie ou si leur corps
traîne quelque part raide mort si les
flammes le consume déjà et qu'il n'en
reste plus trace
nous restons tous pétrifiés
incapable de leur dire un mot plus d'une
fois tu revois une connaissance avec qui
tu as passé quelques temps on doit
durcir son coeur étouffer toute
sensibilité
bientôt de toutes ces vies il ne restera
plus aucune trace effacés comme si elle
n'était jamais n'est
la plupart d'entre eux n'ont pas su ce
qui leur arrivait parfois il savait
quand même quel sort les attendait alors
il priait souvent
il nous était défendue de parler avec
les détenus des convois mais c'était
impossible
c'était à mon sens de dire la vérité à
quiconque franchissait le seuil de la
chambre à gaz là on ne pouvait sauver
personnes là il était trop tard
lorsque la chambre à gaz étaient trop
rempli on jetait souvent des enfants qui
ne pouvaient plus y entrer par dessus la
tête de ceux qui s'y trouvaient déjà
ils étaient entassés serrés les uns
contre les autres et là commence la
panique il comprenait enfin quel sort
les attendait ceux qui étaient encore
dehors dont de nombreux enfants étaient
poussés à l'intérieur des chambres
j'ai entendu les cris désespérés en
polonais et en yiddish les lamentations
à glacer le sang des enfants et des
femmes et ensuite un seul cri terrifiant
cela durera quinze minutes
tout le monde est rentré un ordre roque
retenti que les ss et le commando
spécial quitte la salle ils sortent se
dénombrent les portes se refermer
hermétiquement et les lumières sont
éteintes du dehors on a entendu pendant
quelque temps un bruit de conversation à
cet instant une voiture de luxe pourvu
de l'insigne de la croix rouge
internationale arrive
mais en réalité la voiture de la croix
rouge n'est qu'un leurre elle apporte le
gaz de l'extérieur il n'y en a jamais en
stock dans les crématoires c'est une
précaution infâme mais plus infâmes
encore est le fait que le gaz soit
apportée par une voiture pourvu de la
signe de la croix rouge internationale
un officier ss et un sous-officier du
service de santé en descendent le
sous-officier tient dans ses mains
quatre boîtes en toul verte
après s'être muni d'un masque à gaz un
des officiers enlève le couvercle de la
cheminée il ouvre l'une des boîtes et
déverse le contenu dans l'ouverture de
la cheminée la matière des versets et du
zyklon b qui produit du gaz aussitôt en
contact avec l'air
quand on achetait de gaz il y eut des
hurlements et une bousculade vers les
deux portes
mais celles ci ont résisté à la poussée
les cris qu'on entendait était effrayant
mais au bout de quelques instants un
silence complet régnait
le gazage durer en principe à peu près
un quart d'heure après quoi le système
de ventilation et mis en marche
ensuite d'autres prisonniers ouvre les
portes des chambres à gaz
les appareils d'aération évacue
rapidement le gaz de la salle mais dans
les fentes il en reste toujours une
petite quantité le groupe du
sonderkommando qui pénètre le premier
dans la chambre à gaz et munis de
masques à gaz
la salle est de nouveau puissamment
illuminé
un tableau horrible s'offrent alors à
nos yeux
l'explication réside dans le fait que le
gaz inonde d'abord les couches
inférieures de l'air et ne montrent que
lentement vers le plafond
cela oblige les malheureux à se piétiner
et à grimper les uns sur les autres
quelques mètres plus haut le gaz les as
tu un peu plus tard
qu'elle lutte désespérée pour la vie
je remarque qu'en bas du tas de cadavres
se trouvent les bébés les enfants les
femmes et les vieillards
et au sommet les plus forts
quelques-uns de ceux qui étaient à même
le sol près de la porte était encore en
vie un ss les abattent et alors
l'entassement étaient tels que les gaz
et ne pouvait pas tomber à terre
la position des cadavres des nautes
visiblement que la lutte contre la mort
avait été terrible
il est arrivé plus d'une fois que des
femmes avait accouché dans les chambres
à gaz
puis la chaleur se dissipait c'était le
moment le plus affreux une vision
insoutenable
les gens pressés comme du basalte bloc
compact de pierre s'écroulait hors des
chambres à gaz parfois de deux sous se
faisait entendre aiguë la petite voix
d'un enfant
princesse l'on sortait le brandissent et
en l'air et lui là j'ai une balle dans
la tête plusieurs fois j'ai vu cela et
c'était le plus dur de tous à cela qu'on
ne se faisait jamais
lorsque nous avions vides et le bas de
la chambre à gaz
notre groupe devait la nettoyer à l'aide
de tuyaux pour faire de la place pour le
prochain gazage
ensuite nous devions aller au crématoire
et aidé à transporter les cadavres vers
les fours
puis nous devions traîner les cadavres
vers le monte charge électrique on
pouvait monter 15 cadavres environ à une
fois avec ce monde charge ceux ci
étaient entassés dans la pièce devant
les fours un autre groupe de notre zone
de recommande aux sons chargé
auprès des fours de groupes de détenus
devaient enfournez les cadavres et
veiller à une combustion convenable en
dehors de cela il était chargé de
l'évacuation de la cendre et des eaux
effectuer un tel travail est une épreuve
qui broie le corps et l'âme et nous
pousse dans les abîmes de la folie
quelques-uns d'entre nous se sont jetés
dans le feu parce qu'il n'en pouvait
plus
et voici deux jeune et belle femme posée
là tu restes pétrifiés à regarder elles
ont dû être splendide
elles avaient leur place sur terre est à
présent les voilà étendu sur cette
planche de fer et bientôt va s'ouvrir la
gueule de l'enfer et dans quelques
minutes il ne restera d'elle plus aucun
vestige
voici qu'on est en maintenant un enfant
presser sur le sein de sa mère
l'ascenseur monte et descend
transportent des victimes sans nombre
comme dans un énorme abattoirs sont
empilés la des monceaux de cadavres qui
attendent leur tour attendent qu'on les
enlève 30 bouche infernal flamboie à
présent et engloutissent les victimes
le rôle d'autres détenus était de
s'assurer si les femmes n'avaient pas
intimement dissimuler des bijoux il
avait au préalable vérifié chaque bouche
pour un extraire les dents en or
circulaire 7 2 5 4 il faut enlever les
dents des cadavres avant l'incinération
les dents et objets en or fournit chaque
jour par les quatre crématoire
produisent après la fonte entre 30 et 35
kilos d'or pur
sur le chemin menant des chambres à gaz
aux fausses se tenait plusieurs dentiste
avec des tenailles il ouvrait la bouche
des cadavres les examiner et en retire l
or au coucher du soleil il portait les
paniers remplis de dents en or à leurs
baraquements où il séparait lors des
dents et le fonds d hambach un officier
de la gestapo les surveillait et les
frappait quand le travail n'allait pas
assez vite les fours crématoires en
travaillant sans arrêt à de roulement de
12 heures sur 24 pouvait engloutir au
total cinq mille cadavres en 24 heures
mais les méthodes d'extermination ne
satisfaisait plus qui meurt elle était
trop lente et de nuit à des kilomètres
de distance
on voyait le ciel rougeoyer au-dessus
dahouche vite
oui ma chère health nous devons gagner
la guerre
notre belle allemagne ne doit pas
disparaître même si cela doit coûter
beaucoup de sacrifices il faut qu'il en
soit ainsi car on ne peut ni ne doit
perdre cette guerre sinon nous autres
allemands seront définitivement perdus
alors les juifs tomberont sur nous
exterminons tout ce kit allemand
ce serait un massacre effrayant atroce
lorsqu en automne 1944 les actions
d'extermination furent complètement
arrêté sur ordre de berlin et qu'on nous
donne a pour tâche d'effacer les traces
de l'action d'extermination nous
comprîmes que le moment de notre propre
liquidation approchait nous savions que
les détenus de l'ancien under commando
avait été gazé
les ss nous répétait souvent qu'il ne
laisserait pas survivre un seul témoin
j'ai eu la chance inouïe de ne pas
succomber au cours des nombreuses
sélections dans notre commando spécial
alors que j'avais perdu tout espoir
l'idée que j'allais redevenir un homme
libre me paraissait impossible
j'essaie de m'imaginer ce que pouvait
être le monde sans barbelés son bourreau
100 chambres à gaz sans crématoire sans
hécatombe de cadavres je me demandais
comment réagir m est semblable lorsque
je leur raconte ray ce que j'avais vécu
[Musique]
dix mille tonnes de bombes explosives et
incendiaires larguées sur les villes
allemandes les réduisant entièrement en
cendres tout n'était qu'une mère de
flammes un brasier d'une intensité que
personne n'aurait cru possible montait à
2000 mètres dans le ciel arrachant les
toits déraciné les arbres et balayant
les gens qui transformé en torche
vivante s'enfoncer dans l'asphalté fondu
des rues dans les canaux l'eau brûler
les wagons de tramway est fondée
les ss évacuer le camp à la proche des
armées alliées nous étions des milliers
à marcher jour et nuit par colonne de
5,7 me les juifs marchand les uns
derrière les autres il les pousser à
coups de crosse et de cravache et quand
les hommes defy est tombé à terre il se
précipitait revolver à la main vers ceux
qui gisait sur le sol luttant contre la
mort et tiraient sur tout juif qu'il
n'était plus capable d'avancer
on a marché plusieurs jours sans but
sans boire sans manger épuisé sur les
routes jour après jour les hommes
défaillant on les abandonnait des tirs
se faisait entendre ce qui signifiait
que la sentence était exécuté sur place
de nombreux camarades me disait mort de
rails je n'en peux plus moi même qui
était réduit à une ombre d'homme je les
encourageais il buvait tant d'eau qu'ils
attrapent et des diarrhées et demandé de
faire leurs besoins sur les côtés
s'il tarde d'être au les allemands
arrivaient avec un revolver et leur
tirer une balle dans la tête
en pleine campagne
je me souviens d'avoir aperçu ces
quelques brins d'herbe verte sur un
terre-plein
je me suis précipité dessus pour les
manger plus loin j'ai vu une locomotive
qui se vidange et
j'en ai récupéré l'eau pour boire je
suis malade j'ai le typhus je me
retrouve dans un camion de rapatriement
pour la france
après la désinfection nous sommes
transportés à paris à notre arrivée se
presse une foule nombreuse de parents
d'amis qui harcèlent les malheureux de
questions il nous disait monsieur
monsieur vous avez peut-être connu mon
mari mon fils comme j'aurais voulu leur
répondre ils vont revenir
je passe par l'hôtel lutetia je pense ne
plus avoir de famille jusqu'à ce qu'une
dame s'approche de moi et me disent tu
as mer et et soeurs sont en vie et elle
t'attend de chez toi
je fonce dans mon quartier quand je pose
le pied chez moi j'en laisse ma mère
mais je ne me souviens pas de sa
réaction je l'entends encore me dire
demain je vais avoir des nouvelles de
ton frère gilbert et de ton père
je sais qu'elle ne les reverra jamais et
je ne peux pas la laisser croire ça
c'est pourquoi je lui dis sans
l'aménager c'est impossible ils ont été
gazés et brûlé c'est un choc terrible
par cette seule phrase je lui ôte tout
espoir
elle ne m'en a jamais voulu
durant les premiers jours qui ont suivi
notre retour nous avons été tous je
pense en proie un véritable délire nous
voulions parler être entendu enfin on
nous dit que notre apparence physique
était assez éloquente à elle seule mais
nous ramenions avec nous notre mémoire
notre expérience toutes vivantes et nous
éprouvions un désir frénétique de la
dire tel quel et dès les premiers jours
cependant il nous paraissait impossible
de combler la distance que nous
découvrions entre le langage dont nous
disposions et cette expérience que pour
la plupart nous étions encore en train
de poursuivre dans notre corps
comment nous résigner à ne pas tenter
d'expliquer comment nous en étions venus
là nous y étions encore est cependant
c'était impossible
à peine commencions nous a raconté que
nous suffocation à nous mêmes ce que
nous avions à dire comment c'est alors à
nous paraître inimaginable
j'ai flotté au milieu de cette foule de
gens qui nous attendait qui glissait
tout autour de moi tous dans la foule
qui m'entouraient était prêt à m'aider
était là pour m'aider
avec difficulté j'ai essayé de me
souvenir des gestes qu'on doit faire
pour reprendre la forme d'un vivant dans
la vie
marcher parler
répondre aux questions d'hier où l'on
veut aller
j'avais oublié
je ne voyais ni comment m'y prendre ni
par où commencer
l'entreprise était hors de mes forces
comment réfléchir quand on a oublié tous
les maux
j'étais là
comment
je ne sais
mais était gela
je ne sentais rien je ne on était pas
existé je n'existais pas
combien de temps suis-je rester ainsi en
suspension d'existence
longtemps
je crois me souvenir que j'étais couché
que des gens venaient me voir
il m'embrassait ils me parlaient ils me
posaient des questions
mais ils ont vite cessé je ne répondait
à aucune
j'entendais leur voix de très loin
c'est presque impossible d'expliquer
avec des mots ce qui est arrivé à
l'époque où il n'y avait pas de mots
pourquoi vient-il me voir
pourquoi parle-t-il
que veulent t'ils savoir
ma vie d'avant
avait eu une vie avant
nous les survivants ne sommes pas les
vrais témoins nous sommes ceux qui par
endurance ou par chance n'ont pas touché
le fond
ce qu'ils ont fait ne sont pas revenus
pour raconter ou sont revenus muet
la destruction mené à son terme personne
ne l'a raconté tout comme personne n'est
jamais revenu pour raconter sa propre
mort nous nous parlons à leur place par
délégation
[Musique]